good afternoon folks thanks for being
here
early today the november jobs report
was released and uh
it was grim it shows an economy that's
scaling
and uh remain in the midst of a we
remain in the midst of one of the worst
economic
and job crises in modern history
but it doesn't have to stay that way if
we act
now now i mean now
we can begin to regain momentum and
start to build back a better future
there's no time to lose millions of
people have lost their jobs or had their
hours slashed
they've lost their health insurance or
in danger of losing their health
insurance
one in every six renters is behind in
rent
one in four small businesses can't keep
their doors open
and there's a growing gap in black and
latino unemployment
and the gap remains much too large
and it's deeply troubling that last
month's drop in overall unemployment was
driven by people
who were dropping out of the job market
not because more people were being hired
dropping out of the job market
altogether
they've lost hope of finding a job or
they're taking full-time caregiving
responsibilities as
child centers remain closed and their
children learn remotely
over the past three months 2.3 million
more people
are long-term unemployed meaning
for 23 weeks or more
by far the largest increase on record
this is a dire jobs report it's a
snapshot i might remind you
up to mid november before the surge in
covert cases we predict it many predict
it
and the deaths rise that we've seen in
december
as we head into a very dark winter ahead
for example since october
cities are down 21 000
educators just as schools need schools
need
more help than fighting against the
pandemic
a couple of days ago i spoke with school
cross school crossing guard
a server a restaurant owner and a stage
hand
good people honorable people
decent hard-working americans across the
country
they reminded me of my dad who lost his
job in scranton and eventually moved her
family to delaware
just outside of wilmington a place
called claymont he used to say you've
heard me say it before
joey i don't expect the government to
solve my problems
but i expect them at least to understand
my problems
the folks i'm talking about the folks
out there aren't looking for a handout
they just need help they're in trouble
through
no fault of their own
nothing they did
cause them to have hours cut or lose
their job or drop
out of the market what they need
they need us to understand we're in a
crisis
we need to come together as a nation we
need the congress to act and act
now if congress and president trump fail
to act by the end of december
12 million americans will lose their
unemployment benefits they rely on merry
christmas
unemployment benefits allowing them to
keep food on the table
to keep the lights on and the heat on
pay their bills
emergency paid leave will end
moratorium on evictions will expire
states will lose the vital tools they
need to pay for covet testing and public
health
put yourselves in that position anybody
listening laying awake at night
wondering what's going to happen
tomorrow
it's going to be harder for states to
keep children and educators safe in
schools
to try to provide assistance to keep
small businesses alive
states and cities are already facing
large large budget shortfalls this year
again through no fault of their own
they've already laid off more than a
million workers
even more teachers firefighters cops
will lose their jobs unless federal
government steps up now
and all of this weakens our ability to
control the virus if we don't step up
now
emergency paid leave reduces the spread
of covet
because it allows people to stay home
when they're sick states and cities need
funding
to direct their covert response which is
the only way we're going to end
the economic crisis as well only way
we're going to get people back to work
i'm not alone in saying this situation
is urgent
if we don't act now the future will be
very bleak
americans need help and they need it now
and they need more to come early next
year
but i must tell you i am encouraged by
the bipartisan efforts in the senate
around
900 billion package for relief it's a
bipartisan effort
congress if congress as they work out
the details of this relief package
they're going to have to focus on
resources for
direct public health responses to covet
19.
we need meaningful funding for vaccines
now
so don't lose time and leave people
waiting for additional months
we need serious funding for testing now
need to ramp up testing allow our
schools and business to operate safely
the sooner we pass the funding the
sooner we can turn the corner on covet
19
you know in the week since this election
ended there were questions about whether
democrats and republicans
could work together i know many of you
are skeptical about my view that they
will and can
right now they're showing they can
congress and president trump have to get
this deal
done for the american people but any
package passed
in the lame duck session is not going to
be enough overall
it's critical but it's just a start
congress are going to need to act again
in january
earlier today i consulted with a number
of my economic team
most of which have been announced by now
and vice president harris and i
announced that team last week
as we inherit the public health and
economic crisis
we're working on a plan that we'll put
forward for the next congress
to move fast to control the pandemic to
revive the economy and to build back
better than before we hope to see the
same kind of spirit of bipartisan
cooperation
as we're seeing today our plan is based
on the input from a broad range of
people
the vice president-elect and i have uh
have been meeting with
since winning this election last month
labor leaders
the leading ceos in the country mayors
and governors of both parties parents
educators workers small business owners
there's a consensus that as we battle
covet 19 we have to make sure the
businesses and workers have the tools
the resources and the guidance and
health and safety standards to keep
businesses and schools open safely
it can be done because here's the deal
the fight against covet won't be won by
january in january alone
to truly end this crisis congress is
going to need to fund more testing
as well as a more equitable and free
distribution of the vaccine
we need more economic relief to bridge
through 2021
until this pandemic and economic crisis
are over
and then we need to build back better
i've said it before an independent
analysis by moody's a well-respected
lost
wall street firm projects that my build
back better plan
would create 18.6 million good paying
jobs
it's based on a simple premise reward
work in america
not wealth we're going to invest in
infrastructure
clean energy and manufacturing and so
much more
we'll create millions of good paying
american jobs and get the job market
back in the path
to full employment this will raise
incomes reduce drug prices
advance racial equity across the economy
and restore the backbone of this country
the middle class
look the bottom line
it's essential we provide immediate
relief for working families and
businesses
now not just help them get in the other
side of this painful crisis
but to avoid a much broader economic
cost due to long-term
unemployment and businesses failing
by acting now even with deficit
financing
we can add to growth in the near future
in fact economic research shows
that with conditions like the crisis a
day especially with such low interest
rates
not taking action the action i'm
proposing
will hurt the economy scar the workforce
reduce
growth and add to the national debt
look i know times are tough the
challenges are daunting
but i know we can do this we can create
an economic recovery for all for
everybody
we can move from crisis to recovery and
to resurgence
for lord's sake this is the united
states of america
we've done it before and we'll do it
again
we will i promise you so i thank
the bipartisan group that's trying to
put something together right now
we're going to need more bipartisanship
as we move on
god bless you guys and women are doing
this god bless our country and make god
protect
our troops i'll stop there and i'll
be happy to take some questions
mr president-elect one of the biggest
tasks that you will have when you enter
office is distributing a vaccine
your team has started to meet with the
trump administration to learn
of their plans as you are set to inherit
this task
are you satisfied with the current plans
that are underway
for distributing that vaccine do you
feel that the federal government is
doing enough at this point
and what steps do you think need to be
taken between now and when those first
vaccines go out
well uh there's a lot more that has to
be done
they've clued us in on their planet
on how they plan to distribute the
actual vaccine
to the various states but there is no
detailed plan
that we've seen anyway as to how you get
the vaccine
out of a container into an
injection syringe into somebody's arm
and it's going to be very difficult for
that to be done in this very expensive
proposition for example
you know we agree with their priorities
that they've laid out so far
i do at least my team is looking at it
of dealing with first responders
and and those in nursing homes and in
home care the first people
on the list but we also have to realize
that we're in a situation where
there has to be some equity in the way
this is distributed
and that requires for example right now
we're in a situation where
you have uh you know the leading cause
of death for all americans this week is
uh is covered 19. but blacks and latinos
are three times as likely to die if they
get
covet 19. and so the communities of
color
it's a mass casualty event and so we've
got to figure out
how we make sure we get the vaccine to
those communities
delivering the large amounts of the
vaccine
to the walmarts and the uh and other
major drug chains
is does not get you into a lot of these
neighborhoods
and it doesn't guarantee that it gets
around so we got a lot of work to do
and uh and there has to be the the
equity side of this has to be important
part
of distribution in addition to that the
cost of
actually getting the serum
into a injection into a needle
and then somebody's arm costs a lot of
money it takes a lot of people
it takes a lot of folks to be able to
get that done
and we have to have a much better way
than we've seen thus far
as to how it's distributed in some
states
like the governor of utah say just
delivered to the capital i can take care
of it in our conversation
well that could be true but in large
states like california texas illinois
florida et cetera
it's not that easy there has to be a
overall plan that's what we're working
on right now
and that's why i ask dr fauci
to stay on and to be my chief advisor on
this issue but also to
be part of a covet team and on your
cabinet you are facing a lot of pressure
to add more diversity to your
administration you have
civil rights groups and lawmakers
pushing you to do this
to make sure that you make good on your
promise
and you look at your cabinet
announcement so far and they have
include some diverse figures but i
specifically want to hone in on those
big four
and so far when it comes to secretary of
state and treasury you have nominated a
white man and a white
woman so looking at attorney general and
the department of defense would you
commit to nominating a person of color
for those positions
look it's each one of these groups jobs
to push
push their leaders to make sure there's
greater diversity
what i can promise you is when this is
all said and done
you see everyone that i've announced and
it's going to be in the next several
weeks we'll have it all out there
you're going to see significant
diversity i'm not going to tell you now
exactly what i'm going to do in any
department but i promise you it'll be
the single most diverse cabinet
based on race color based on
uh gender that's ever existed in the
united states of america
so no commitment on those spots a
commitment of what i just said will be
the most diverse cabinet
and the main spots in both white house
as well as the cabinet positions
thank you
thank you mr president-elect
you just said a couple of minutes ago
that there's no time to waste when it
comes to economic stimulus
but democrats and republicans have been
in the stalemate for
several months as they have been
negotiating and trying to talk
about what kind of stimulus to put
together you were elected
by more than 80 million people to
try to break that log jam can you talk
about specifically what you have
done over these past several weeks to
actually work with democrats and
republicans speaking to congressional
leaders
to get them to agree
on a stimulus package and what do you
say to
people like senator sanders on the left
flank of your party who have come out
against
this stimulus program already they have
said that this 900 billion dollar
deal is not good enough well
it would be kind of stupid for me to
tell you what i did wouldn't it
it would be kind of hard to do it again
i told you all that i was confident we'd
get a bipartisan agreement on this stuff
and i think we will not just on this
package but i think beyond
and the last thing i'm going to do is
tell you
strategically how i go about this i
remember used to get asked the same
thing
when i was putting together significant
deals between democrats and republicans
when i was a senator
vice president it's just not a very
smart thing for
it's like me asking you tell me how you
get your sources and how did you get
those sources you got
in order to get that story that would be
ridiculous for you to tell me or your
colleagues how you did it
all i can say is i'm confident there are
sufficient number
of democrats and republicans in the
united states senate
along with significant votes coming out
of the house of representatives
to put together a serious package
that will keep us from going off the
edge here provide the kind of resources
that are needed immediately
it's not going to satisfy everybody but
the option is
if you insist on everything we're likely
to get nothing on both sides
and so i think they're on their way to
being able to come up with a package
that
meets the basic immediate needs that we
have
but i've made it real clear it's just a
down payment
this is not the end of the deal so uh
um i've been relatively good at
negotiating over my career because i
never
number one reveal something somebody
doesn't want me to in the deal and
number two
because i always keep my word there are
a number of progressives including
senator sanders who have
criticized this deal in part because it
does not include the 1200
checks that were in the last deal what
do you say
about that they say that the american
people who are hurting
maybe not the small businesses but just
the everyday families they don't have
anything in this deal they're not
getting
any of the stimulus that's in this 900
billion that's not what i understand but
i think it would be better if they had
the 1200
i understand that may be still in play
uh
i'm not going to comment on the specific
details the whole purpose of this
is we've got to make sure people aren't
thrown out of their apartments
lose their homes are able to have
unemployment insurance they can continue
to feed their families on
as we grow back the economy be in a
position where
we provide for help to localities so
they're not continuing to lay off
school teachers and firefighters etc
first responders
and to make sure we're in a position
that we're able to
generate the kind of growth that as a
consequence of this by
allowing it costs a lot of money to keep
schools and businesses open
on the covet side of the equation
they're all pieces should be
there's much more if i were writing it
you know i think the proposal that
quite frankly the heroes act that the
house passed i
that's what i would support but you know
this is a
uh a democracy uh and there are
you you you've got to find a sweet spot
where you have enough people
willing to move in a direction that gets
us
a long way down the road but isn't the
whole answer
thank you thank you
thank you mr president-elect you're
describing this compromise bill as a
down payment that you'll push congress
to do more once you're in office
but this bill is already more than
republican leaders want to spend
what if this isn't a down payment what
if this bill is it
what are your options then to get
americans additional relief
i never start off thinking that way i
always start off believing we can get it
done
we'll get it done but it's been more
than six months this fight has been
going on mitch mcconnell still hasn't
even signed off yet on this compromise
bill
what makes you so confident that you
will be able to get republicans to go
big
once you're in office well because the
country's going to be in
dire dire dire straits if they don't
have you reached out to leader mcconnell
have the two of you spoken yet
we'll be in dire trouble if we don't get
cooperation i believe we will
thank you
thank you mr president elect you noted
today that one in six
renters are behind in their rent
millions of americans remain
unemployed you say the situation is
urgent when you come into office
you expect to pass executive orders
dealing with those specific issues
and also do you at all plan to pass
trillions of dollars of aid is that what
you have in mind when you say we need to
go big
are we looking at billions of dollars
we're looking at hundreds of billions of
dollars
and look again
um i've learned after hanging around in
this business for a while
the last thing you do before you begin a
negotiation is lay out a dr
lay down a drop dead marker and if it's
not this i'm not going to talk to you
i think there's a lot we can get done
and i think people are going to see the
overwhelming necessity what's going to
start to happen
is a lot of folks who represent
republican districts are going to find
the republican neighbors are in real
trouble
as things get worse they're gonna find
that
uh there's an overwhelming need as these
these
numbers skyrocketed you remember my
saying that i believe the experts we'd
had at least another 250 dead
before the end of the year and they went
oh no all right guess what look what's
happening
it's going to get much worse it's going
to get much worse
and so i believe that there are enough
republicans
who will join enough democrats in the
united states senate to get a majority
along with the house to get it done and
but we'll see
we'll see this is this is step at a time
and on executive orders
well i'd ask you executive orders that
are from
totally within the purview of an
executive but one of the things i don't
like is i like people i don't like
people saying
that i can buy executive order do the
following things which there's no basis
in the constitution that suggests it can
be done
so there are certain things i can do i
can issue executive orders uh
pulling back some of the executive
orders that trump put forward
but i can't issue an executive order
saying we're going to spend x
billion dollars on this issue without
getting the
congress appropriates and is responsible
for distributing that money
and then quickly on the coronavirus
vaccine you talked about
getting it into african-american and
vulnerable populations
you said yourself that you're willing to
get the vaccine publicly to get people
to feel safe but there are people
already telling me well president-elect
biden has good health care if there's
some complications
he might have better health care than me
african-americans around the country
what more can you do to convince people
that the vaccine
is safe for them and does that mean
you'll at all lean on any
existing members of the corona tax force
i know that you have
committed to keeping dr fauci but is
there dr burks is there anyone else that
you might be leaning on
to convince people there are a lot of
people i'm looking to convince people in
the task force
and the task force will continue to be
expanded with really fine people
and uh look i think
actions of presidents matter
and i'm going to say something that
i think the african-american community
latino community have known i've never
misrepresented anything to them
and that if as you all keep pointing out
i'm the oldest president ever elected
although i'm actually only 47 but all
kidding aside
i think that my taking the vaccine
and people seeing me take that vaccine
is going to give some confidence and
but you know i i said early on you may
remember
i think you may have asked me the
question i may be mistaken
but i said early on that i think one of
the things that bothers me the most
is by the wild assertions the
administration was making about
how this was going to go away and inject
bleach and all those kinds of things
it was diminishing confidence across the
board
and the american people overall but
particularly in this administration with
the african-american latino community
what i hear from my friends in the
community not but blocks from here
as we stand is that we're not going to
be the guinea pigs
we're not going to be the guinea pigs
well the fact of the matter is that
um they won't be you're going to see
tens of millions of americans
uh taking the vaccine and you're going
to see the present united states and
three of the four living former
presidents doing it publicly as well
it's all about and look it's uh
it's going to take some effort to
rebuild confidence in science
because it's been so diminished in this
administration
thus far so uh but i will and by the way
in the meantime
i got to make sure that the vaccine is
both free
and available and that any follow-up on
the vaccine
is free and available that relates to
any health complications from it so
there's ways we can deal with
some of these issues biden has good
health care therefore
i but i don't have good health care
that's another thing we're working on
from day one i've been working on it at
this moment
um and so my hope is that we can instill
reinstill some confidence in to be able
to believe
the president of the united states when
he or she speaks
thank you thank you very much
thank you mr president-elect a lot of
people
are wondering what your inauguration is
going to look like considering so much
considering that we are still in the
middle of uh the coronavirus pandemic
so i would like to hear what you
envisioned for the inauguration uh do
you expect a scale down event
are you still planning to take the oath
on the west front of the capitol
whether it be a parade uh whether it be
balls
what do you envision for your
inauguration um
first and foremost thing is we're going
to follow again the science and
recommendation of the experts on
keeping people safe so it is highly
unlikely there will be
a million people on the mall going all
the way down to the memorial
um i think we'll see where we're in
discussion with the house leadership and
the senate leadership as to what they
plan
for the inauguration particularly those
two hundred thousand
facility spots they control
but i think you're going to see
something that's closer to what the
convention was like
than the typical inauguration first and
foremost
and my objective is to keep america safe
but still allow people to celebrate
to celebrate and see one another
celebrated
and so we're in consultation my team is
in consultation with folks who help us
put on the convention
as well as with our colleagues
republican and democratic colleagues
in charge of the administration the
inauguration
my guess is there probably will not be a
gigantic
inaugural parade on down pennsylvania
avenue
uh but my guess is you'll see a lot of
virtual activity
in states all across america engaging
even more people
than before but that's in entrained now
and uh um and i i'm not in a position to
give you an example of exactly um
you know what it will look like i uh
um but i promise you
it'll be available either virtually or
in person for many
and my guesses will still be some it was
to be a platform ceremony
but i don't know exactly how it's all
going to work out the key is
keeping people safe i can't
do a super version of
the president's announcement in the rose
garden uh
nationwide so it's just gonna have to be
more imaginative but i think like i said
i think the
the convention we put on
really opened up avenues that we never
thought existed and i doubt it would be
another democratic
re at least a democratic convention that
it's a straight like it always has been
i think we include more people people
want to celebrate people want to be able
to say
we've passed the baton we're moving on
democracy has functioned i wish i could
tell you more but we as as
those decisions are made they'll be
announced okay and i also wanted to ask
you about your relationship with senator
mcconnell
i know the two of you have a long
history of actually working together on
various deals
have you talked to him since the
election and
given the partisan nature of congress
right now
how do you convince him that it's in
america's best interest to work with you
going forward
i don't think i have to convince him of
that
he knows me he knows i'm as straight as
an arrow when i
negotiate he knows i
keep commitments and i never attempt to
embarrass
the opposition um
there's some things that i think are
are just ready for the kind of
compromise that democrats and
republicans are prepared to engage in
absent the president of the united
president president united states
attitudes on some of these issues
infrastructure
dealing with health issues dealing with
the fight against cancer
dealing with education i think there's a
number of things
as i said before
we've got to take the vitriol out of
politics
i know there's a lot of people on both
sides who want to continue
to go after and punish the opposition
i get that i get the fact that an awful
lot of americans are
disappointed i was elected president
fortunately there's seven million more
that
were happy than disappointed but i get
that
and there's a lot of democrats who are
angry and want to
strike back republicans but i've said
from the beginning i've
i think i've conducted myself this way
throughout my career
i learned that early lesson it's always
appropriate to question other man and
woman's judgment
but never their motive once you question
their motive
then in fact there's no way to get to go
you're in the pocket of the cement
industry let's do a deal on highways
no possibility and so
when i've dealt with mitch mcconnell in
the past as a vice president or as a
senator
we haven't engaged in that activity
doesn't mean we can get to an agreement
i'm not asking anybody to abandon their
principles
but i do think it makes no sense to
engage in vitriol
and trying to get the place where i
can't believe
that a majority of republicans don't
understand we need a new infrastructure
in america if there is nothing to do
with jobs or a green economy
just too many bridges that are going to
collapse too many roads and disrepair
two republican states that every time it
floods they flood out their
their their their their water systems
are polluted
it's just these are common problems and
i'm confident
it's going to be hard and i'm confident
we can get to agreement on a number of
things but we have consequence
thank you all so very very much is that
it thank you
appreciate it thank you
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but i
would
do everything in my power just like i
don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide
i'll do everything in my power as a
president united states to encourage
people
to do the right thing and when they do
it demonstrate that it matters
that's why i said on my in my inaugural
speech i'm going to ask people to
commit for 100 days to wear a mask
not because i'm asking it to for any
reason to punish this is not a political
issue it's become
one but if people do it for a hundred
days
in the middle of what will be still a
raging crisis
and the vaccine is able to be
distributed they're going to see deaths
drop
off the edge they're going to see
hundreds of thousands of people
not getting sick and my hope is they'll
be then inclined to say okay
it's worth it's worth the patriotic duty
to go ahead and protect other people
thank you all so very much